millions of people who live along the
u.s gulf coast
could face the threat of two tropical
storms early next week
meteorologist jeff beradelli is tracking
both systems more this morning
and we have to say this is history in
the making
jeff it is you know extreme weather
coast to coast and with two systems in
the gulf of mexico at the same time if
they're both hurricanes we have never
seen that
before that is tropical storm laura that
right there is tropical storm marco
laura has become better formed overnight
we see a little big blow-up of
thunderstorms right near the u.s and
british virgin islands
and even marco has gotten better formed
overnight now both of these systems are
going to be moving west northwest
marco is going to be moving into the
gulf of mexico that makes landfall first
laura's a little more complicated
because it's going to ride the spine of
the greater antilles and
it could be disrupted a little bit
before it gets into the gulf of mexico
and starts to utilize
you know really high octane fuel
extraordinarily warm water temperatures
are probably going to make this a
hurricane before landfall
about 24 hours apart marco makes
landfall around texas probably tuesday
and then it looks like probably on
wednesday laura's going to make landfall
around louisiana give or take could be
anywhere though as you can see big doma
high pressure in the west the heat wave
continues it's not as bad as it was
which is good news but
look at that moisture flow into
california dry lightning is certainly
possible as we head through the weekend
and the air quality is horrible look at
all that smoke especially trapped in the
valleys believe it or not
it goes coast to coast in the east
believe it or not you may see some haze
in the atmosphere and i'll leave you
with this as we continue to warm the
climate fires are getting bigger and
bigger
we have burned as many acres this week
in california
as they typically see in an average
season in one
week oh jeff nobody can get a break in
2020 it seems like thank you